this video is made possible by nordvpn
go to nordvpn.com forward slash vpen and
get a two-year plan with a huge discount
plus four months free more on this in a
moment
[Music]
thirty years after what is known as
black Wednesday the pound has once again
experienced days of Maximum tension in
September 2022 while on 16th of
September 1992 the bank of England
itself had to succumb to the financial
assault led by George Soros this time it
was the British government that
unleashed the storm on 23rd of September
2022 a bizarre story began that ended
with an IMF reprimand a massive outflow
of investors an emergency intervention
by the central bank to try to contain
the chaos and the dismissal of the
chancellor of the exchequer Quasi
quateng in just 38 days after taking
Office UK could trigger a global crisis
as pound collapses while bond yields
soar Larry Summers says in a short
period of time uncertainty doubts fear
and the worst Omens have surrounded the
British economy things are not going
well at all in less than a year the
interest rate demanded by the market for
UK government bonds has increased
tenfold as you can see while at the end
of 2021 the British government could
issue two-year bonds paying little more
than 0.4 percent following the pound
crisis the required rates exceed did
four percent
[Music]
and to top it off we can find news like
this UK inflation could top 22 next year
warns Goldman Sachs so the question is
what on Earth is going on in London what
could explain why the cost of British
debt has exceeded that of countries like
Spain Greece and Italy and the most
important question of all why did Liz
truss come up with a plan that drove the
markets crazy only to toss it in the
trash just a few days later
visualpolitik community in this video
we're going to answer all these
questions but first we need to know
exactly where things stand this is the
necessary starting point for
understanding the actions of the British
government let's get started
but before we go any further let me tell
you about one of the most common cyber
security threats fishing imagine you get
an email from Facebook saying there has
been a login to your account from
Vanuatu click here if it wasn't you
concerned you click enter your email and
password and that's it you've just
fallen for the Trap this is how phishing
Works scammers send thousands of emails
pretending to be Banks social media
platforms and even government
departments with the same shared purpose
to get you to click on the link they
send you this link will take you to a
website that may seem authentic but nope
nothing of the sort so once we know
about the scam how can we avoid it first
of all by activating nordvpn's cybersec
account which will automatically block
known phishing sites and for the unknown
ones pay close attention to who is
sending you these kinds of emails avoid
clicking and go directly through your
account to the websites that you need to
access in addition to improving your
protection against fishing with nordvpn
you can surf Without Borders choosing
from over 5400 Ultra fast servers from
59 countries all around the world what's
more you can use it on up to six devices
on every major platform Windows Android
iOS Mac OS Linux so don't wait any
longer go to nordvpn.com forward slash
vpen and get a two-year plan with a huge
discount plus four months for free and
remember that you have 30 days to change
your mind no strings attached and now
let's get back to the video
[Music]
let's be clear the UK has a serious
problem since the financial crisis of
2008 the economy has not been the same
the latest example as you can see it
became the only G7 member whose economy
was smaller in mid-2022 and it had been
before the pandemic even the recovery of
a country like Italy was Stronger but
this is just the tip of the iceberg
since the financial crisis real GDP per
capita in the United Kingdom has barely
grown and has fallen far behind
countries such as the United States and
Germany we're talking about a difference
of almost 10 points this lack of growth
less than four percent in 14 years has
meant that public services have had to
be increasingly financed by debt and
also by the highest tax burden in the
country in the last 40 years
[Music]
and what was to blame productivity to
give you an idea between 2008 and 2020
labor productivity in the UK Bailey grew
by 0 0.4 percent less than half of the
oecd average in Hard Cash terms this
meant that compared to countries such as
France and Germany the British lost four
thousand dollars per person and it shows
so the question is why on Earth is there
such little growth in British
productivity
[Music]
well among other factors it's because in
this country business investment that is
investment in machines factories
computers work centers etc etc is at
Rock Bottom you don't believe me well
take a look at this
[Music]
it is the lowest of all G7 countries
even Italy scored better than them
Financial hyper specialization and
uncertainty caused by brexit have a lot
to do with this poor performance which
in addition has had other consequences
for example Mega Financial concentration
lack of investment and poor productivity
performance have made the UK
increasingly dependent on the outside
world resulting in a current account
deficit of over eight percent
fundamentally this is a consequence of
the strong trade deficit that is Imports
far exceed exports
wait a minute this is not necessarily
bad as long as Financial exports are
able to compensate for it and if not
just look at how the United States does
it the problem is that in order to do
that you have to have the confidence of
investors in the rest of the world so
that they keep buying pounds because if
you lose that confidence then you can
really get into a huge crisis of course
this is not the only consequence of
under investment and poor productivity
growth another much more visible
consequence has to do precisely with
wages
[Music]
to give you an idea while in 2007
British wages after inflation were
higher than those of France or Germany
these days they are already lower why
well because between 2010 and 2019 it
practically didn't grow at all in
addition low-income British households
are also much poorer 22 and 21 poorer
than the French and German households
respectively
and to top it all off public debt has a
percentage of GDP has reached its
highest level since 1960. so as you can
see the British economy is neither at
its best nor is it what we would call
buoyant the last few years have been
rather dismal and that is precisely why
the new prime minister Boris Johnson's
replacement at number 10 Downing Street
Liz truss presented a mega plan to end
all of plans listen up in these tough
times we need to step up
I'm determined to get Britain moving to
get us through the Tempest and to put us
on a stronger footing as a nation
trussonomics the plan
[Music]
just two weeks after taking over the
reins at 10 Downing Street Liz truss's
new government hit the ground running
and presented an economic program that
broke completely with what had been
conservative party policy for the past
decade Liz truss along with her ex
Chancellor of the exchequer crazy
quateng designed a bombshell of tax cuts
regulation removal and public spending
in the hopes of Reviving The British
economy a shot of adrenaline to get the
country's economic heart beating again
according to the Prime Minister herself
the fundamental objective of this plan
was to do away with redistribution
policies and focus entirely on
production and productivity so put
another way to stop thinking about how
to distribute the money and focus on how
to create it again what was completely
unsustainable was this idea we could
simply tax our way to prosperity and
burst through the fact that it was a
70-year high of tax where did you want
that to end quasi-guartang Chancellor of
the exchequer and keep in mind that this
is not an improvisation or a plan
designed at the last minute not at all
in 2012 both Liz truss and quasiquarting
Co authored the book Britannia Unchained
which broke down many of these ideas and
of course when they came to be in power
they had the opportunity to put their
theories into practice now although many
of you already know this perfectly well
there is one question that we have to
answer what exactly did this supposed
return to the Thatcher ERA with some
shades of difference consist of what you
see on the one hand the government made
public its intention to carry out the
largest tax cut since 1972.
this includes a host of measures such as
the reversal of the profit tax increase
to 19 a one point reduction in income
tax for all taxpayers the reduction of
taxes on Capital reduction of Social
Security contributions the freezing of
excise taxes and even initially because
later as we will see they had to suspend
it the reduction by five points off the
highest income tax bracket in other
words no radical change but many small
changes that together will amount to the
largest tax cut carried out by a British
government in the last five Decades of
course now with the dismissal of the
former Chancellor of the ex-chequer it
seems that many if not most of these tax
measures will come to nothing at the
moment the reversal of the corporate tax
increase and the reduction of the top
income tax bracket seemed doomed to be
ostracized
but no this plan was not all about taxes
and maybe many of the other things will
stay
[Music]
the new government has also pledged to
slash regulations for example they
started to do this by suspending the
legal limits on bonuses in the financial
sector a limit that was established by
the European Union in 2014 and that's
only the beginning we welcome the
Chancellor's clear Direction and new
approach and his strong endorsement of
the financial services sector as the
Catalyst for the UK economy the measures
announced today are the start of what is
needed to unleash the full strength of
the sector statement from UK Finance the
UK Financial employers organization they
also announced the creation of numerous
special economic zones throughout the
country these zones will have certain
tax and Regulatory advantages and their
number one objective will be to increase
business investment it was something
like an evolution of the Johnson
government's Freeport project that we
covered previously here on visualpolitik
investment zones go further than the
recent Freeport regime as well as
greater tax incentives to attract
businesses they also reduced the
bureaucracy and protracted planning
process which often stops investments
from happening at all together Ben
Houchin conservative teas Valley mayor
now then let's see if I were to ask you
what's the most worrying problem in
Europe today three two one exactly
energy or rather the cost of energy
[Music]
Korean and the use of energy as a weapon
strengthening our energy security is an
absolute priority Jacob Reese mogg UK
energy Minister well in this matter the
trust government has made it very clear
the UK has to get hold of an abundant
and at the same time cheap source of
energy and the question is how do they
expect to do that well in addition to
maintaining the nuclear plans of the
previous administration this government
has also announced new exploration
permits in the North Sea and above all
the end of the moratorium on fracking
low taxes deregulation special economic
zones and fracking it sounds like the
Golden Dream of brexit at least of
course of the brexit advocated by
conservatives and pro-free Market
supporters doesn't it
[Music]
we are talking about a huge package of
what in the economic world is known as
supply-side policies that had a very
clear objective to get the British
economy to wake up once and for all and
return to growth which given the
circumstances may make a lot of sense
after all gaining competitiveness was
the main argument in favor of brexit
low growth isn't just numbers on a
spreadsheet low growth means lower wages
fewer opportunities and less money to
spend on the things that make life
better but wait a minute we started this
video by saying what you all already
know but the government's plan ended
with an emergency Central Bank
intervention to stop the pound from
plummeting which Liz truss eventually
cut short so the question is why on
Earth did the markets become so nervous
about a tax cut it seems
counter-intuitive doesn't it
[Music]
well visualpolitik viewers the answer
has a lot to do with the second part of
the trust plan the part that Still
Remains and that has nothing to do with
Margaret Thatcher along with tax cuts
deregulation fracking and everything
else the government has also promised a
huge increase in public spending
specifically in two areas do you
remember what is the biggest concern of
households businesses and governments
across Europe right now the cost of
energy well the UK is no exception and
yes fracking a new exploration Pursuit
may help but the problem is that it
won't do it fast enough so do you know
what the government of Liz truss has
done well they have announced a maximum
price for Energy paid by households and
businesses the difference will be
covered with a subsidy that will be paid
by the government and as you can see on
the screen it is the largest energy
subsidy scheme in Europe we're talking
about the gigantic cost that could be
between 100 billion and 200 billion
pounds
the objective is that the energy crisis
does not affect the national economy it
will not push companies and families
until the country achieves alternative
sources of cheap Supply the problem is
that this raises the suspicion that the
subsidy and with it the bill could drag
on longer than expected however we must
insist that we're talking about a
temporary measure not an expense that
will be Consolidated over time
but that's not even the end of it at the
same time Secretary of Defense Ben
Wallace confirmed what was an Open
Secret by the end of this decade the
United Kingdom will raise its military
budget to 100 billion pounds that's more
than 110 billion dollars that means more
than doubling the current budget and
raising the military efforts to three
percent of GDP in just eight years in
other words from now on every year that
passes the British military budget will
grow generously which obviously means
more spending more deficit and more debt
well there we have it if we take into
account the promised tax cuts and
spending increases we find ourselves
with something like a huge fiscal bomb
eerily similar to the one that triggered
the crisis and one that has ended up
blowing everything out of the water
we're talking about a huge gap that over
the next few years could lead to more
than 80 billion pounds a year a huge
amount of additional money to add to the
already large budget hole and perhaps
that is why the government did not
present its plan to the office for
Budget responsibility why because they
would criticize it the problem is that
this office which by the way was set up
by David Cameron AS precisely that
function now what effect could this plan
have on the British economy and do the
markets have any confidence that London
can pay its bills well let's see
[Music]
the Panic
well visual politic viewers Tracy's plan
may have made some sense but it was a
huge gamble where results are not
assured among other reasons because
despite everything there are serious
doubts that what was announced would be
enough to boost the British economy so
the presentation of the plan had three
immediate effects firstly the pound
plummeted and reached its lowest level
against the dollar secondly government
bond yields soared above even countries
such as Italy Greece and Spain maximum
tension in the United Kingdom the pound
plunges to 1971 laws and its bond yields
4.2 percent and thirdly given the two
previous consequences there is about to
be a huge financial crash with the
Pension funds
why because fixed income yields have
been so low over the past few years that
these funds have been investing more and
more in interest rate derivatives to try
to improve their yield levels and of
course when the storm hit their
derivatives suddenly lost value and they
had to increase the collateral required
to trade these products this led them to
a liquidity crisis and having to sell
assets at full speed and in a way this
is what forced the central bank to step
in with a 65 billion pound emergency
plan with this intervention and the
promise to present a budget stability
plan nerves were carved and with it the
pound has partially recovered
but the tension in the markets continued
and the political fire was raging but
why was there so much fear in the market
and could it be that investors do not
like low taxes well the truth is that we
can find three very clear reasons
[Music]
first of all the huge budget Gap this
plan entailed was basically going to be
financed with debt and we're talking
about an amount that over the next few
years could total more than 300 billion
pounds of additional debt and the
problem is that we are no longer talking
about near zero rates as was the case a
short time ago now the yield on British
public debt exceeds four percent in
other words the country would have to
start paying a lot more interest this
would further complicate the Public
Accounts there is a real risk that
International investors will lose
confidence in the UK government and that
will lead to a sterling crisis the
market is asking how are you going to
pay for this Market doubting Chief
investment officer at Blue Bay Asset
Management secondly because it was
feared that this plan could further fuel
inflation and the loss of the value of
the pound which in turn would increase
the cost of imports and the current
account deficit this could lead to more
inflation and further falls in the power
it would be back to square one thirdly
if this scenario came to pass at the
same time as the government maintained
its fiscal pump the Central Bank may be
forced to raise interest rates further
to fight inflation and stabilize the
pound and then higher rate could hurt
growth as they could reduce demand for
credit and investment projects in
addition they would also further raise
the cost of government debt further
complicating the fiscal Outlook you see
what the markets feared was that this
plan could end up causing a huge crisis
spiral now if this were the case why on
Earth did the government come up with
such a plan
[Music]
well basically because what truss and
Quantum were hoping was that thanks to
all these measures the British economy
would wake up and form better than the
rest of Europe and that growth would
then dilute or sidestep all the problems
we're talking about a lot of debt true
but the spending was essentially
temporary and we also have to bear in
mind that the government expected to
freeze public spending in the medium
term markets move all the time it is
very important to stay calm and focus on
the long-term strategy quasi-quarting
Chancellor of the exchequer in the end
if one thing is clear it is that he was
not given enough time quoting has become
one of the chancellors of the exchequer
who spent the least amount of time in
office just 38 days which by the way
seems to suggest a huge betrayal and a
huge disloyalty t on the part of the
Prime Minister because this was not the
quieteng plan but fundamentally it was
the truss quatteng blang anyway what do
you want me to say The British economy
probably needed this kind of Revival the
problem is that perhaps the government
was too ambitious after all reconciling
rubber taxes with a huge increase in
public spending may not be the best idea
in the world right now although in our
patreon bulleting we gave you some Clues
as to why the criticism may have been
overblown be that as it may the pressure
has been so extreme that the government
has had to backtrack fire quatting and
announce a new last minute improvised
plan that remains to be seen what seems
clear is that what there will not be is
much political Capital kwate's dismissal
may have brought Liz trust time but
right now her future looks complicated
at least that's what the polls are
saying today but again let's not kid
ourselves regarding the failed plan one
way or another perhaps more Progressive
this is the path that brexit forces to
follow if the UK wants to succeed it has
to become a very competitive place in
the world and to achieve this there is
only one possible Direction Liz trust
herself seemed to be clear about that at
least until now I have three priorities
for our economy
growth
growth and growth but now it's your turn
what do you think of the British
government's plan do you think
traconomics would have been successful
or would it have meant the end of the
conservative government era what path
should they follow now leave us your
answers in the comments and now if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like And subscribe to
visualpolitik if you've not yet done so
thank you so very much for watching all
the best I'll see you next time
[Music]